[Music]
we recently
did a frequently asked questions video
where we mentioned that james
our master of microscopes was on the
lookout for a super rare ciliate with
retractable tentacles called
thyssana morpha this video is not
a surprise announcement that we've found
one the thysanomorpha
remains elusive for now
but it turns out that thysenomorpha is
not the only
super rare ciliate with retractable
tentacles
what you're looking at right now might
not immediately stand out
you've got a sea of green organisms and
then
in the middle is a clearish oval
and that oval is what we're going to
talk about today
because over the course of three years
james's many many excursions into
different water
have turned up only three of them
and as rare as the species is we think
the footage he's taken
might be even harder to come by
the organism is called actinobellina and
it showed up
in a paper that a ciliate scientist sent
to james titled
protozoa of especial interest from van
cortlandt park
new york written by gary n calkins
the paper was an old one published in
1901
and if you haven't been able to tell yet
we love
hold papers like this they've often been
written in a way that feels
a lot more casual than the way academic
papers are structured today
it can feel like you're just reading
somebody's journal entry
or a travel blog that just happens to
contain important biological insight
calkins paper even starts with an
extended description of van cortlandt
park
complete with railway directions and
instructions on how to reach the exact
pond he sampled from
so james read this delightful paper
which includes
an extended passage of the act in
abelina in action
and the next morning he found one
we mentioned that he's only found three
actini bolina in three years
this is the third one found the morning
after
reading calkins paper when james
observed his first actinibolina
he didn't yet know how rare they were
and his second actinibolina died quickly
likely due
to some kind of temperature shock so
with this
third member of the species james made
sure to take
extra care to keep it alive and
follow it around so he could observe it
as much as possible
now what makes actinobellina so notable
are the tentacles lining its body they
can be a little difficult to make out
from far away but you can see the faint
lines of them
surrounding the body with great
magnification though
you can start to see the bundles of
cilia and tentacles a bit better
the tentacles can reach to around 2.5
times the length of the organism's
diameter when fully outstretched
but even more cool than how far the
tentacles go out
is how far in they go
like when the actinibolina needs to move
around and doesn't want some
cumbersome extensions getting in the way
and when it's
zipping around the microcosmos the
actinobalinas
cilia seem to have more of a vibration
to them than the usual
wave-like stroke associated with cilia
in fact they kind of resemble flagella
more than cilia
but we don't know much about why or
how this movement works
in his description of actinibolina
calkins writes
it is when the animal is quiet that it
takes in food
it remains for hours sometimes without
giving
any sign of feeding but the tentacles
are stretched out
to their greatest length and it appears
merely waiting
for something to come
we don't know if he meant for it to
sound as ominous as it does
but it certainly feels appropriate for a
tentacled predator
part of the fun of reading these old
papers is getting to see
how well these observations made by
scientists over a century ago
match up to what we can see now it's
like exchanging letters
with the past and our little lactino
bolina
is the courier and it's all even more
exciting for us in this case
because as far as we can tell not many
people
have gotten footage of the actinibolina
in the midst
of a hunt but while calkins may not have
had the technology we have
today to capture what he saw he did
provide detailed descriptions that
line up nicely starting with the
surprisingly particular tastes of the
actinibolina
organisms pass and pass
but nothing tempts the hunter until
a specific prey comes along the
unsuspecting ciliate
called halteria the actinibolina
stabs it with a tentacle which is loaded
with a toxicist
at the end to immobilize the prey and
then
the tentacle draws the food in to its
inevitable end
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the actinibolina digests its meal but as
calcan himself said
it is insatiable so it retracts its
tentacles and leaves
seeking out a new spot to stretch out
and ensnare its next meal
and here it is again catching another
halteria with its tentacles
using the word tentacle makes the
actinibolina sound
like an octopus but watching the hunt in
action it looks
more like a porcupine with its quills
fully extended
but a porcupine that uses its quills to
skewer meals
instead of protect itself and then it
retracts the quills
so it can rush on to the next spot
we might be testing the limits of our
comparisons right now but that's okay
according to our calculations we've got
about a year
until we see our next actinibolina so
when that rolls around
we'll be ready with some new ones
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
and thank you as always to all the
people on the screen right now
these are our patrons on patreon and
right now
we're pushing to get to five thousand
dollars a month
which is when we'll be getting a brand
new objective that's a
lens for the bottom of the microscope
for our dic microscope
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss
check out jam and germs on instagram and
if you want to see more from us
there is always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
you